Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
Don't stop believing. Hold on to that feeling.
Good. Rob core. How's your day.
What's going on guys. This is Robin. I love journey, but we are covering the.
Man Dr. Doom tie in for the King and black and this story.
It's amazing. This story is hilarious and I absolutely.
I love it. Right. It's great to kind of have this reprieve, right. I mean,
there's some serious notes in here, but it's also just a really, really,
really good story. So initially this picks up at some point in the past, right?
This,
this is a really important in so far as what happens as much as the meaning
behind it. But it's one of these things where for like his birthday,
as a little kid, Tony stark has given a piece of prime real estate by his dad.
He buys this place called the Johnson and Bernstein building, uh,
this like prime Manhattan real estate.
Now Tony stark ends up selling it when he's like 13 years old for 6 million
bucks of his dad's like, you know, cool, like good job, you know,
you made a profit, you know, so that's kind of, that's kind of interesting,
but the funny thing about this is that when Tony gets the gift,
he gets kind of pause it off and it's like, thanks dad. And he's like, no son,
Santa's got it for you. And he's like, it's okay.
Like I know how this stuff works.
And his dad gives him this really good piece of advice. And he says,
there are times in this life when you don't really want to suck the magic out of
things, right. Just let the Badger, you know, let the magic be what it is,
even if you know the truth behind it.
Sometimes it's just more fun to buy into the illusion.
And the reason why is because when you lose that magic,
the world will turn cold and gray and the spice of life will basically be gone.
And that's kind of where Ironman is here at the moment, right?
Not in so far as he's lost the magic or anything like that.
But because what he's facing is basically the death of Eddie Brock and the sense
that it was his actions that led to Eddie dying, right?
The fact that he went and got that Grendel Symbion he brought it back believing
that Eddie could basically use it. He could tap into Knoll.
It appeared to be more than Eddie could handle in any Brocket seems to have
basically been killed because of it. And he literally flat-lined in the story.
And so because of that, Tony starts kind of coping with the struggle of this,
right? That he was directly responsible for the death of a hero.
More so than that,
the death of Eddie Brock basically seems to be the death of everything else,
right. That Eddie seemed to be the only one who could really stand against it.
And then suddenly out of nowhere, he's met by the arrival of Dr. Doom.
Now we're not really given an explanation as to why Dr. Dumas here,
but given the nature of his character,
we can largely surmise that he was watching everything unfold in Liberia and
then seeing what it was at Ironman did and knowing Ironman,
the way he does basically comes here.
The important thing to understand is that there is a kind of,
of history there between iron man and Dr. Duke specifically the concept of
infamous Ironman, right? That in the aftermath of civil war two,
when Tony stark was killed, that Dr. Doom basically took over the world,
iron man. He's like, there's, there needs to be an iron man out there. Right?
So I'm going to take over that role.
It was kind of his way of redeeming himself, right?
Going from like the traditional villain to trying to become a good guy.
And it was a great story.
It was not the most financially successful story Marvel wrote,
but it was a great story. I loved infamous Ironman, but because of that,
there's a little bit of history here and there's a lot of respect between the
two. And so with that being the case, it's kind of him not so much, you know,
kind of nursing him back to health, but asking him some important questions.
If it were me who had died, right.
You would grab the Greenville semi at you'd bonded it to me.
Would you mourn me in the same way?
And it's one of these things where it's kind of like, you know, I don't,
I don't know if, you know,
if I really understand what it is that you're getting out here,
but before they're really able to get, you know, too far into this discussion,
suddenly like iron man picks up on what looks like some object flying in the
sky, right. Something flying in the sky.
And he's kind of like what in the world? You know? And, and like, of course,
you know, Dr. Doom kind of picks up on it too. And he's like,
is that an doctor names? Like no iron man's like, it's December. Right? Like,
I don't even really remember if it's a Semper anymore. Right.
Everything kind of blurs together, you know? And, and of course,
Dr. Doom understands what it is that iron man is asking here. And he was like,
no, what you're asking is absurd. Right. Like it's not even Christmas Eve.
Right. He's like, but, but like IMS, like, but look at the thing though, man,
like, it looks like it really is, you know, like, like it really looks,
it looks like that's really, that's really the case, you know? And, and like,
they're both trying to deny the truth, but the reality is it's Santa.
It really is Santa Claus. The problem with this is that Santa Claus has been.
Again.
Well, this has been taken over by Knoll and this is amazing.
I just like sleigh bells, sting and perdition, you know, it's amazing, right?
Like a victimized Santa.
Claus. And this.
Is one of these things where like Dr. Doom has like the best response ever.
Right. He's like, it cannot be your hollowed gift giver. Right?
TIS merely some solos perversion.
You can meet one.
I love doctrine dooms. I love the way he talks, but I am. It's like, no, man.
Like, like we can't let this happen. Right. Like, look, yes.
Things are kind of crazy right now. Yes. No one has shown up on earth.
He's pretty much conquered everybody in New York,
but we cannot let him ruin the holidays.
We cannot let him enslave Santa Claus to his whims. Right.
So like they literally go hunting after him. Now this is, this is the,
this is the funniest thing. Like Dr. Doom shows up here and then like, uh, like,
like I am as like, dude watch out, we will watch for the reindeer. Right?
Like keep an eye on those things. And they spit venom at Dr. Duke right now.
Of course they get burned off because of, you know,
Dr. Doom being mystic and so on and so forth.
And then like Santa Claus throws an explosive president at them,
which sends them flying into a building.
And.
And, and it's, it's kind of wild, right?
Because in the middle of all this iron man's like, Jesus, like this is insane,
right? Like first I killed Eddie Brock and now I've got to kill Santa.
Claus. And this was kind.
Of a cool little moment here, Dr. Doom sort of muses on the nature of Eddie.
Right? He says Eddie Brock was weak, that he was an addict in many ways,
a slave to the Symbian. And it's one of these things where I am,
it's kind of like, I don't know if that's really the case.
The world would have been a much worse place. Had we not had Eddie,
Eddie Brock became venom, venom,
pushed Spider-Man to new Heights because before venom Spider-Man,
hadn't really faced a villain like that.
And so Spider-Man had to push himself to greater Heights.
And so in turn that made Spiderman better, Spider-Man becoming better,
made the world superheroes better.
And then there's even stories where Eddie Brock was a,
was a hero where he fought alongside the, the,
the various heroes who were out there and basically was the reason why they
survived. Right? So pad Eddie not been there.
The world would have been a far more screwed up place than it is. Right.
Had it not been for any,
they never even would have known that NOLA was coming in the first place. Right.
So it's one of these situations where Eddie has, uh, has an important role here.
And so what you end up getting is Dr. Doom kind of pilling Ironman.
Like I'm here to simply tell you that Eddie,
Eddie Brock dying was worth the sacrifice. And the question of iron man is like,
why was it worth losing Eddie and the response of, of Dr. Dumas?
Because it gave us you because in your actions and in your desire to prove that
Eddie's death was an accident, that you're not somebody who's clumsy or buffoon,
that what you've done, whether,
whether it was by your own direct action or your unintentional action,
was that you effectively merged the venom symbiont with your extremist armor.
You've created a new victimized suit.
And so what this does is it will allow you to go forward in this battle against
snow, using a kind of technology that you'd never really utilized before.
You can call it a Knoll Buster suit, if you want to.
I don't know if I would call it that yet,
because you'll probably end up having something like that later on.
But it's iron, man's new venom suits.
We're seeing a paradigm shift in terms of how iron man's armor works,
because now it's, it's a,
it's a living synthetic organism that he is essentially enslaved in bonded
to his suit. It's cool because it's not like extremis right.
Or anything like that. It's kind of a modified version of it.
But jumping back into the fray, he basically ends up grabbing,
grabbing Santa Claus. Right. And it's like, okay,
like we got to regain control of the sleigh and we've got to take out Santa.
And then he's like experience my pain, dear. That's what he calls his reindeer,
his pain, dear. This is just good, old fashioned fun.
And this is what comics are supposed to be. Right.
The people who take themselves too seriously, we'll be like,
this is not how comics are supposed to be. They're supposed to be 100% serious,
100% of the time and never deviate and never have fun. Screw that. Right.
I love comics that are fun.
And just sometimes they're goofy and it's great to have like, especially now,
right with the world being the way it is, we're edging to the end of 2020,
Oh God. Right. We need some humor in this world. And Dr.
Doom came up with iron man who has a modified,
minimized iron man suit facing off against a minimized Santa Claus. It's cool.
Right. It's the kind of humor that we needed. And it's great. Right.
So ultimately where iron man tries to seize control of the sleigh,
this basically leads to, to,
to essentially Santa Claus falling out of it and just plummeting down into a
vehicle. Right. And it's kinda like, okay, so iron man's like,
did I kill Santa Claus just now? Right. Like, did I, did I, did I have that?
Did I just kill him right now? Kind of a crazy thing.
Like I think I just killed Santa Claus.
Now the other thing that we ended up learning here, and this is something cool.
The other thing that we end up learning here is that the suit of iron man
functions almost identical to a venom Simeon or any kind of symbiotic in the
sense that pieces of a suit had broken off because of the fact that it's tied to
the Symbion, it actually returns to them. And that's cool, right?
Like literally pieces of a suit kind of liquefy and bond back to him again.
Right. Which is, which is really awesome. Now Santa Claus,
of course is not dead. He just explodes out of this car,
screaming obscenities at everybody, you know? And he's like,
don't you believe in me? You know? And that kind of a thing, you know, and it's,
and it's kinda nuts. He says like, you know,
nothing's going to go back to normal, right? Like this Christmas.
And for all time forward, Christmas will be a black Christmas. Right.
And then it just goes on the attack against, you know, Ironman and Dr. Doom.
Now of course, iron man gets the upper hand. And then in turn,
what he actually ends up doing is it seems like he lets off this kind of
repulsor blast that actually blows the Symbio directly off of Santa Claus.
Right. Like not to get off of him.
So now iron man looks like he has a kind of modified version of Dylan's
abilities. Probably not in the same extreme. Right.
He can't really control symbionts he can't destroy them on a whim,
but he has the ability to kind of knock them off, right.
To basically blow them off of an individual and kind of remove them in that way.
Right. So the ability to remove ischemia from somebody else, no,
this is something that's noticed by, by Dr. Duke, right?
It's something that's noticed by him. And it's like, this is cool, man. Right?
This is, this is interesting, but it's, it's, it's,
it's kind of a funny line because Dr. Doom's like, you have eradicated Nicholas,
the jolliest of men, but ultimately of course, you know, Santa Claus,
isn't dead. And, uh, he basically ends up kind of coming to right. You know,
he kind of, kind of comes back and he looks at Tony. He's like, you know,
Tony stark, you were always such a good boy and Victor,
one of the naughtiest to have ever lived. And so we just kind of like,
I'm outta here. So he ends up, he ends up leaving. Now,
one of the things that they realized when they basically smashed his license up
is they realized that he's not really Santa Claus.
He's just a guy named Mike Dunwoody. Right. Who just kind of lives out there.
And I think New Jersey is where he's from, from, from pyramids, New Jersey.
And that said, he's just an average, Joe. But then suddenly, like,
they kind of start asking questions. One of the funny things is adopted him,
wants the suit of Ironman. Right.
So you can use it for his own ends to kind of destroy Nolan iron. Man's like,
that's not going to happen. Right. I don't trust. And he's like,
don't dismiss my viability. And he's like, no,
it's really just because you're a villain, if anything else, but that's,
that's not really going to happen.
But as they're walking along and they're kind of leaving,
Dr. Duma has this thought, he's like, you know,
and literally he says like something perplexes me, right?
Michael Dunwoody referred to both of us by our real names. And I am, it's like,
well, neither of us really has a secret identity, but then the doctor deems,
like, but in tandem, he, so arrogantly quantified this,
some moral value of our respective deeds and IMS, like also not really hard,
you know? And then Dr. Tim's like thought, and then I imagine,
are you telling me,
you believe in Santa Dr. Jamie was like preposterous by merely conducting an
intellectual investigation of what just occurred. Dr. Dan believes in Santa,
that needs to be said, but this isn't, this is why I love this. Right.
It's a fun story. You know, that's ultimately, that was kind of like, okay,
you know, maybe it was Santa, maybe it wasn't.
But what it does do is it actually kind of gives iron man this sort of reprieve
that he needed to kind of regain his confidence a bit and to kind of get past
the fact that his actions led to the death of Eddie Brock. Yes they did.
But moping over the fact that Eddie's dead is not going to do anybody any good.
There'll be time for that. Right.
There'll be time for iron man to sit down and come to grips with the fact that
he killed Eddie in the moment they need the mind of Tony stark. They need him,
right. They need him at his absolute best.
He's got to get back into the battle again,
but the story does leave off on a pretty cool moment where Dr. Doom ponders,
whether or not Santa Claus could be a sorcerer of Supreme. Both that being said,
guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you guys are new here to comments, explain,
make sure you guys are the sub button to become part of the Rob Ford.
If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and I will catch you all later.
[Inaudible].